[Musik]
ich heiße sie ganz herzlich willkommen
aus dem haus der religionen in bern seit
vier jahren sind hier acht
religionsgemeinschaften unter einem dach
es ist der ideale ort für die erste
ausgabe
unser streitfragen da wollen wir nämlich
mit menschen mit gästen aus
verschiedenen religionsgemeinschaften
über strittige themen diskutieren heute
ist es die streitfrage abtreibung ein
altes heftig umstrittenes thema das
inzwischen wieder neue brisanz und
aktualität erhalten hat ist es wichtig
ein menschliches leben weg zu machen um
ein problem zu lösen ist es richtig
einen auftragsmörder zu mieten um ein
problem zu lösen
es ist nicht richtig menschliches leben
weg zu machen sei es noch so klein
mit diesen worten schreckte franziskus
unlängst viele frauen auf ausgerechnet
der reform papst vergleicht abtreibungen
mit der auftragsmord katholische und
feministische frauenorganisationen
während sich mit protesten und petition
gegen die kriminalisierung von
abtreibungen in der schweiz nimmt die
zahl der schwangerschaftsabbrüche er ab
doch der streit rührt an eine grundfrage
ist werden das leben unter allen
umständen schützenswert wann beginnt das
menschliche leben mit neuen
medizinischen tests können krankheiten
behinderungen und geschlecht heute sehr
früh erkannt werden
viele religiöse traditionen begegnen der
abtreibung mit skepsis gesetzgeber aber
auch die religionsgemeinschaften sind
gefordert ihre haltungen zu überprüfen
ja die haltung verschiedener
religionsgemeinschaften zur streitfrage
abtreibung wollen wir jetzt hier in
dieser runde diskutieren mit anette b
klassist jüdische theologin mit valentin
abgottspon er ist freidenker und atheist
und mit christina aus der aussie ist
evangelische theologin herzlich
willkommen
das sind von außen betrachtet ist es für
viele so christentum und abtreibung das
geht gar nicht zusammen ist das so na ja
zuerst ist es schon gehört es zu den
tiefsten überzeugungen im christentum
dass menschliches leben nicht nur
menschliches leben aber hier auch vor
allem menschliches leben einen wert hat
und eine würde hat ohne eine vorleistung
man muss nicht bestimmte eigenschaften
haben man muss nicht eine bestimmte
leistung erbringen um eine würde zu
haben und deswegen ist eine zutiefst
christliche überzeugung leben
menschliches leben ist schützenswert
aber gerade protestanten sind auch der
überzeugung dass es die freiheit gibt
den eigenen lebensentwurf zu entwickeln
dass es nicht ein system von dogmen gibt
was man ungesehen es allen überstellten
sollte und auch dass es zur
mitmenschlichkeit gehört erst einmal mit
respekt auf den andersdenkenden
einzugehen und von daher eröffnet das
ein weites feld für gespräche und zu
sagen es geht nicht zusammen das ist zu
schnell
gut wir werden sehen welche konsequenzen
diese position hat frau birthler wies
das aus der sicht des juden als ich
denke das christentum hat von uns
übernommen dass das leben absolut
schützenswert ist und heilig im judentum
ist eigentlich der vers auf denen wir
uns beziehen wenn wir über abtreibung
diskutieren
der berühmte satz auge um auge zahn um
zahn was weniger bekannt ist ist was vor
diesem satz steht da steht nämlich wenn
zwei männer streiten und treffen eine
schwangere frau die da aus irgendwelchen
gründen zufällig stand und sie hat eine
fehlgeburt dann bezahlt er eine strafe
als ob das ein eigentums schaden ist
wenn aber ein schaden entsteht dann gilt
neffe start erscheint hat ein leben um
leben auge um auge zahn um zahn
das heißt daraus kann man schliessen was
da verloren gegangen ist war dann wohl
noch gar kein leben und daraus entspannt
sich nun eine bunte debatte in viele
richtungen
okay das ist halt die grundlage aber sei
es jetzt diese diese stelle aus der
bibel für heute
jüdische leben heißt ja wir beziehen uns
immer rück auf die diskussion in der
vergangenheit also die wichtigste
nächste stelle ist dann die mischna das
ist das älteste jüdische gesetzbuch in
diesem exodus text also exodus 21 da
ging es ja nicht um abtreibung sondern
um so einen dummen zufall dass da jemand
im weg stand in der mischna dasteht wenn
eine frau schwierigkeiten bei einer
geburt hat dann darf man den fötus
zerschneiden und stückweise aus ihr
heraus nehmen denn ihr leben geht vor
seinen das ist natürlich die logische
schlussfolgerung dass da ja noch eben
vorher gar kein leben war
aber wenn schon die mehrheit
herausgekommen ist dann darf man nicht
ein leben wegen eines anderen lebens
zurückdrängen erste unterscheidung jetzt
aber noch valentin abgottspon glaubens
gehört der papst sagt abtreibung nicht
zu vergleichen die auftragsmord ihre
reaktion nennt oder die die medien
nennen ihn zu häufig reform papst
ich sehe nicht unsere form papst er ist
so ein selbstbedienungsladen also
einerseits ist der ultra-konservative
eben auch bei solchen dingen was er über
homosexualität oder einfach anders
sexualität gesagt hat da muss man auch
nicht zu viel hoffnung hineinsetzen als
ob jetzt die katholische kirche eine
reformierte wäre dann wäre sie
reformiert wenn sie das wäre oder würde
und ich sehe da schon viel
kritikwürdiges also einfach zu sagen
auftragsmord das ist schon das geht also
schon sehr sehr weit
ich finde dann da ist er häufig ein
besserer kirchenaustritts katalysator
als dass ich sein kann aber nehmen wir
es noch vom papst etwas weg zum thema
gekommen dass bei grundsätzlich ist
vielleicht ein bisschen ethisch das
heuer auf der falschen bühne oder werden
die begriffe nicht ganz klar gehabt zum
beispiel denke ich ist es auch eine
falsche frage ist das leben also
eigentlich lebt auch schon eine eizelle
für sich die frage ist dass menschliches
leben ist für mich auch nicht die
relevanteste sondern kann es leid
empfinden
kann es schmerzen empfinden und da geht
eigentlich die biologie die medizin und
fast alles davon aus mindestens bis zum
12 12 wochen nach der empfängnis ist das
also unrealistisch dass es wirklich
schon ein schmerzempfinden hat die
abwägung ist wichtig und da wird sind
die diskussion interessant also wo ist
das recht der frau zu entscheiden
idealerweise wenn das machbar ist und
eine beziehung da es zu einem mann soll
auch den man mitreden dürfen
idealerweise da fängt es an für mich
spannend zu werden
für mich gelten aber keine religiösen
gründe eine an ein konzept wie seele ist
dann für mich einfach nicht gut genug
definiert das ist schon die große
auslegeordnung aber ich höre aus für sie
so eine bemerkung einfach viel zu
pauschal sie wollen da die färinger sich
also schon sehr frech also eigentlich
ist das schon es ist eine ohrfeige für
ganz ganz viele frauen zurück und
visionen das ja eigentlich widerstand
der in verschiedenen ländern auch in der
schweiz
bei ihnen ist bereits angeklungen oder
diese lebensschutz auf der einen seite
auf der anderen seite die einzelne
situation aber das richtige haus gehört
entscheidung der frau ich werde eben
wirklich sagen die diskussion beginnt
nicht erst bei der frage kann es leider
nicht leiten das ist nur schon
philosophisch gibt es schon eine
diskussion vorher also will man die
folgen beurteilen oder will man wie kant
zum beispiel da braucht man gar nicht
theologe sein sagen es gibt gewisse
rechte gewisse prinzipien da geht es
nicht um die folgen sondern es ist schon
in sicht falsch und ich glaube beim
passt klar ich schrecke auch zurück wenn
er sagt das ist auftragsmord aber was er
auch vorher gesagt hat darf man ein
menschliches leben zerstören um ein
problem zu beseitigen
ich glaube schon dass das etwas
bedenkenswert das ist es geht ja nicht
einfach darum dass man einen stein aus
dem weg liegt weil er einem im weg ist
sondern was wir hier tun es diskutieren
darüber was machen wir mit was wollen
wir im gesetz haben dass frauen und
männer da gebe ich ihnen sehr recht
entscheiden dürfen über werden das leben
dass eventuell ein mensch werden könnte
was passiert da auch in der gesellschaft
und ich finde es wichtig dass man auch
unterstreicht und immer wieder sagt da
geht es um etwas was zutiefst an unsere
intuition und ich bin papst auch das war
erstens dass er da noch mal alles
zugespitzt hat dass wir drüber
diskutieren können dass der dialog
wieder in die öffentlichkeit kommt und
nicht einfach vom tisch gewischt wird
mit der bemerkung das soll jede frau für
sich selber entscheiden eben also der
bauch gehört mir das wäre für sie zu
wenig ja das ist für mich zu wenig
bekommen die institutionen nicht aus der
griechischen philosophie
also da ist doch dass zum beispiel
plateau oder so sagt da ist dieses
werdende leben ist schon gültiges leben
jetzt hatten wir schon bereit die
griechische philosophie jetzt mal noch
vor bürger in judentum
da habe ich jetzt alles gehört also
katholizismus sehr sehr streng gegen
abtreibung wir kommen wahrscheinlich
noch darauf bis auf ganz wenige
ausnahmen zb wir neben dass das leben
der mutter gefährdet ist aber ansonsten
ganz trägt ich habe da herausgehört die
evangelische theologen die sich seit
sind sie sagen da gibt es doch noch
differenzieren uns ist das natürlich
nicht kennen dann muss die leben ist
etwa dieser muss anfangen zu diskutieren
genau wie es im judentum
also im judentum ist konsens wenn die
mutter probleme hat soll man abtreiben
die auslegungs spanne ist was sind
probleme da gehen auch die meisten also
bis hin in die orthodoxie dass es
gesundheitliche probleme gibt aber dann
fängt es auch schon an auch schon in der
orthodoxie und dann im progressiven
judentums probleme können auch
psychische seien familiäre ökonomische
also dass man im grunde die situation
der mutter analysiert und guckt maas hat
die für schwierigkeiten
durch dieses kind und wenn da
schwierigkeiten sind dann soll man ja
das problem im grunde die sprache
aufzunehmen lösen ja ich würde
interessieren bevor wir jetzt weitere
themen ansprechen die mit der abteilung
zusammenhängen wie sie mit der bezug ist
zum thema sie sind ja rabbinerin also
jüdische theologin aber rabbinerin in
ausbildung
und ich denke sie haben selber keine
familie dass sie das thema von daher aus
der berufspraxis sage ich mal
also alle also bei uns geht das ja mit
fragen und antworten an rabin
sogenannten response uns die enten
eigentlich fast alle damit dass der
konkrete einzelfall der soll mit dem
lokalen rabbiner oder der lokalen
rabbinerin besprochen werden also es ist
eben zum beispiel grundsätzlich erlaubt
oder eben eingeschränkt erlaubt aber
dass man dann den einzelfall mit einer
frau bespricht und das ist an meine
aufgabe in der gemeindearbeit von daher
muss ich wissen was in die positionen
und meiner auffassung ist dass religion
einen menschen stützt das heißt wie
immer die frau entscheidet ob sie sagt
ich möchte das kind auch mit
schwierigkeiten
das kann ich religiös genauso begründen
wie wenn sie sagt ich treibe ab das kann
man religiös genauso begründen so dass
die entscheidung gestärkt wird und das
selbstbewusstsein des menschen im grunde
unterstrichen wird ich denke dass das ja
die aufgabe von religion wir menschen
sie mit dem thema zu tun
es ist also ich hatte relativ selten
damit zu tun ich kenne eine freundin von
mir die viele neue rituale auch
geschrieben hat es gibt zum beispiel
gebet nach schwangerschaftsabbruch es
gibt rituale dass man zb vergeht und so
also es ist eigentlich jetzt nicht so
großes thema weil es jetzt auch nicht so
diskutiert es ist eigentlich relativ
klarheit aber eben seelsorgerlichen
einzelgesprächen schon okay valentin
abgottspon sie sind gerade zum zweiten
mal vor kurzer zeit vater geworden
hatten sie mit dem thema mal berührung
oder in meinem persönlichen leben
eigentlich nicht meine frau und die
mutter meiner wunderbaren kinder ist
kinderärztin hat auch eben auf der
neonatologie gearbeitet weitere
ausbildung also ich bin da ein bisschen
näher dran am thema hat auch diskutiert
mit ihr ich bin ein fan ist sie ist eine
feministinnen und das gehört auch dazu
dass man diese themen diskutiert von
daher bin ich im thema schon drin
ich habe aber nie die frage stellen
müssen
mit mix mit mit welcher partei er ihn
auch immer also einfach das kam nicht in
meinem leben vor
aber in diskussion ist schon am ende
mein fazit gewesen
die fristenlösung die es da und hinter
die dürfen wir nur schon aus praktischen
politischen gründen nicht zurückfallen
also dass das dann eher so ein
politischer kampf kein keinen ethischer
impetus oder irgendetwas intuitives das
mich da und manchmal auch klartext reden
lässt sondern ist so eine sache der
politik wie wollen wir unsere
gesellschaft organisieren wie sehr
wollen wir dass die religion in solche
dinge eben reinredet genau dass die
regelung die in der schweiz seit 2002
gilt wie ist es bei ihnen war aus da sie
sind tochter einer süßen mutter der
tochter genau ich habe eine tochter und
war spätgebärende und von daher kann ich
hätte ich ihn die ganze maschinerie
hinein kommen können ich habe in basel
in den frauen spital geboren und bin
dort betreut worden sehr gut betreut
worden und habe am anfang auch das mit
meinem mann gesprochen und gesagt wir
wollen keine invasiven tests wir wollen
nicht weiter gehen als ultraschall weil
ich mir sehr bewusst war
sobald ich etwas weiß fordert dass auch
schon eine entscheidung von mir also man
hat auch da mal die nacken falsche an
geguckt und ich musste vorher den
entscheid fällen ich bin schwanger
ich will fall scheint es ist toll und
was kommt kommt das hatte mit meinem
gott vertrauen zu tun
ich dachte das ist wenn es behindert
sein wird dann wird die kraft damit
kommen wenn es nicht dann ist auch gut
so zu sagen aber das war eine
entscheidung und aber ich habe
freundinnen die anders entschieden haben
ich habe freundinnen die abgetrieben
haben und ich habe bisschen mitgekriegt
was das für ein regen ist und ich bin
die letzte die sagen würde du darfst das
nicht insofern stehe ich sehr
hinter der auf nächsten lösungen ich
finde auch das ist eine sache die wir
als rechtsgemeinschaft in der schweiz
entschieden haben und das ist gut so
und trotzdem möchte ich dran bleiben und
sagen leute
es sind keine steine und die frage
dürfen wir einfach so um probleme aus
dem weg zu lösen oder ist es nicht
gerade auch unsere pflicht als
gesellschaft die probleme die sich
stellen für eine familie mit einem
behinderten kind dass wir da auch
hingucken und nicht versuchen eben da
das kind weg zum schon da ihre
formulierung eben einen stein ja was
genau wie grün und sie selber haben von
diesem recht auf nichtwissen nämlich
dann dank dass wenn ich auch noch
ständig genommen
und da kommen wir vielleicht noch das
wird auch immer so ein bisschen enger
wir haben jetzt mal eine position aus
dem judentum und christentum
verschiedene facetten bereits gehört
eine position eines freidenker es gibt
hier im haus der religion natürlich noch
andere religionsgemeinschaften da drüben
sitzt säkular marin kam er ist hindu
priester ist hier priester im tempel
hier im hinter tempo aus der religionen
wie ist es denn im hinduismus wie steht
der hinduismus das sind ja viele
verschiedene religionen steht der
hinduismus zur abtreibung
abtreibung ist eigentlich im hinduismus
auch verboten weil wir glauben diese
wiedergeburt kreis viele viele viele
erwarten für ein new yorker zu nehmen
weil wir glauben es gibt 84 millionen
lebewesen am schlussendlich bei
komponenten menschlicher körper aber
hätte gott gibt uns das alles gesagt mit
diesem körper kann man üben und wieder
mit einem kursrutsch kehren sondern
häufig erbrechen die wiedergeburt an und
offenbar auch das schöpferische der
mensch sollte also überhaupt nicht
eingreifen da raus gibt es
notsituationen im hintergrund das ist so
geregelt aber es gibt auch einen
situation bei vergewaltigung oder
schwierigkeiten für die mutter dann die
mutter ist so ständig am schluss
entscheiden kann auch eine gesetze geben
aber man sollte auch achten
der betroffene ein problem hat bin jetzt
auch erstaunt weil von außen der
hinduismus gilt ja vielen als sehr
offene religion vielleicht sogar mit
sexualität kann man super und so jetzt
diese strenge haltung zur abtreibung ja
wie ich gehört dass es nicht zu sagen
ein stein sondern dasein ein lebewesen
eigentlich wissen entdeckt
so lag der gedanke das heißt wir dürfen
keine lebewesen töten und stellt man vor
wenn wir dann mein körper bekommt dass
wir einfach so entscheidung schwierig
gibt es denn verschiedene strömungen die
liberale die offener sind oder ist das
einfach mal einen gemeinsamen nenner
also hin versuche seine riesen gebiet
sogar indien noch lässiger es gehört
auch mit dem kultur zu tun und auch die
hierarchie von studium und das kann auch
ein bisschen anders sein also bei uns im
hinduismus meistens viele wünschen dass
nicht eine abtreibung man muss sie
vorher denken einhaltung ist erlaubt
wenn sie dachten dann müssen wir achten
aber ernst nehmen und respektieren
interessante präzisierung dass sie bei
der verhütung ist dann nicht so streng
ist wie kommt das bei ihnen sind sie
auch so erstaunt wie ich entspannt die
spannung zwischen im prinzip verboten ja
aber wenn es dann zu problemen kommt
nichts bei der frau bei das ist ja bei
uns im gesetz ganz ähnlich nicht im
prinzip eigentlich verboten und ich
hab's noch mal nachgelesen ist zwischen
zwischen tötung und totschlag glaube ich
angeordnet im gesetz ist schon ebenso
nicht einfach bei eigentumsdelikten zum
beispiel
und wenn es dann aber hart auf hart
kommt eben dann dann gibt es eine reihe
von bestimmungen die sagen dann ist die
frau
diejenige die es ist ja tatsächlich so
in der schweiz ist abtreibung also
schwangerschaftsabbruch ist nicht
einfach lecker
es ist straffrei unter denen und denen
bedingungen
und eben teilweise sind auch nach der
zwölften woche wenn eben gewisse
gesundheitliche dinge gewisse
medizinische indikationen das vorsehen
und es gibt diesen spruch der kommt aus
dem englischen schwangerschafts abbrüche
oder eben abtreibungen sollten straffrei
sein sicher also gesund und möglichst
treu und das ist auch meine meinung ich
bin nicht dafür dass man abtreibung als
verhütungsmittel sieht denn das ist
jedes mal es ist auch ein eingriff es
ist eine medizinische prozeduren die
kann bei frauen auch etwas auslösen es
ist es nicht einfach nichts
und deswegen bin ich auch dermaßen
kritisch gegenüber gerade der
katholischen kirche die daneben
verhütungsmittel nicht mal in der ehe
haben möchte also kupfer damme wie soll
das zusammengehen das erzählt die
katholische position erinnerte von orga
zeichen wie das wie das zusammengeht
deutlich der unterscheidung das ebenso
sieht damaligen gab sagt dass da die
verhütung eben doch erlaubt ist eine
übersicht über die haltung der
verschiedenen großen weltreligionen zum
thema abtreibung finden sie ab morgen
online eine sehr strenge und restriktive
haltung zur abtreibung gibt es auch in
teilen der westlichen kirchen und bei
christlichen gemeinschaften
wir haben uns dort umgehört wo über 15
jahren hat das stimmvolk die
fristenlösung angenommen
seither ist eine abtreibung in den
ersten drei schwangerschaftsmonaten
legal
dennoch machen christliche
organisationen zunehmend mobil gegen
schwangerschafts abbrüche
wir haben roland graf besucht der
theologe präsidiert die schweizer
sektion von pro life international hli
morgen 0,1 millimeter große im block c
und denkt sich ja kontinuierlich
untersucht und im wind sehe was für ein
fantastisches entwicklungspotenziale
massa neben versteckt denn mit der nano
radix ihr müsst ihr fantastisch jetzt
sie würden mit der bibel argumente
es ist jedoch klar dass das gebot du
sollst nicht töten
da gilt weil es habe eine mensch ist
farfan
jetzt geht es aber auch
konfliktsituationen in der schweiz hat
mir der kompromiss vor der fristenlösung
funde wie stehen sie denn zu teilen
es ist sich ein demokratischer entscheid
gefällt worden ist aber es weiß ich
wünsche dass sie nun denken stattfindet
man muss ein rating abfolge für frauen
das geht sehr viel depressionen - die ja
sicher wenn man schon unfallprävention
macht im straßenverkehr abtriebs
prävention machen
seit jahren demonstrieren lebensschützer
mit dem marsch für schlappe gegen
abtreibung wie hier vor wenigen wochen
in bern
veranstalter der demonstration sind
christliche organisationen beider
konfessionen und aus freikirchen regula
lehmann hat den marsch mit organisiert
ich glaube dass jedes leben jeder mensch
jedes kinder jedes ungeborene kind er
würde halt und das recht auf leben und
dass es nicht richtig oder ist es recht
ich überlebe vor anderen zufügen
ich glaube dass gott als schöpfer vom
leben jedem level wert gibt und dass es
darum nur die menge kompetenz liegt
darüber zu entscheiden ob es an das
lieber jetzt quasi lebenswertes oder
nicht ich hatte früh stelle sich
für das rückschrittlich und das sehr
freundlich zu setzen
warum sie erhöht den druck auf frau
massiv sieht die fristenlösung kirche
immer wieder dass frauen sei das umfeld
gar nicht so komisch es ist legalisiert
gambo abschnitt der b wir wissen aber
dass sehr viele frauen später sagen
die körper nicht unterstützt hätte wäre
ich nicht wo ab triebe will eigentlich
kann ich das gar nicht von mir aus würde
ja faust auch die fristenlösung
frauenfeindlich oder fortschrittlich
das ist natürlich ein ganz spezifisches
milieu in der wahrscheinlich frau
lehmann ihre gesprächspartnerinnen
findet die sagen ich werde ich hätte
nicht abgetrieben und ich werde gedrängt
nein ich finde es ist ein stück regelung
in einem gebiet was vorher ganz
schwierig ungeregelt war zwar nicht so
dass es vorher keine abtreibungen gar es
ist ja nicht so dass erst wenn im gesetz
ist legal ist dass es dann passiert im
gegenteil dass da die möglichkeit
darüber zu sprechen ist klar zu regeln
dass an spitälern von ausgebildeten
ärztinnen und ärzten durchzuführen und
nicht in einem hinterhof und vor allem
eben es ist eine möglichkeit darüber
dass zum zum dialog zu bringen und es
die frauen entscheiden sich eher nicht
im stillen kämmerlein okay jetzt frage
ich habe und dann gehen sie sondern es
ist verbunden mit einem gespräch mit
beratung mit information und insofern
ein da kann ich nicht zustimmen dass das
ein rückschritt sein
das milieu das aus dem diese ideen
kommen die haben ja auch jetzt so
aktuell ist das narrativ dieses pps zu
lancieren und ich sag' das jetzt ein
bisschen polemisch post aus orangen
sensor und da wird jetzt postuliert dass
es spezifische
posttraumatische belastungsstörungen
gibt wegen abtreibung das lässt sich
medizinisch eigentlich noch nicht eben
wie festnahmen das ist weder dem dsm
noch im city oder so drin
ich werfe diesen leuten teilweise auch
vor dass sie sowas sogar begrüßen
ähnlich wie leute wie bischof lowe
kommen und sagen ja homosexualität ist
heilbar und jungen die leiden ja da sage
ich zurück weswegen leiten sie teilweise
wegen eure intoleranz und beile denen
einredet es sei schlimm
noch einmal ich bin nicht dafür dass man
abtreibungen wie eine verhütungsmittel
anwendet aber den frauen teilweise noch
ein schlechtes gewissen machen und ein
reden also ich habe auch schon mit
leuten kontakt gehabt bei denen ich das
also nicht nur annehmen musste dass sie
das fass begrüßen dass es den frauen ein
bisschen schlecht geht sondern da da
hatte ich also wirklich belege dafür nur
zufrieden lösung vielleicht ist wichtig
mal auch eine zahl zu sagen es waren
ungefähr 12.000 abtreibungen im jahr vor
der einführung jetzt sind es ungefähr
10.000 im jahr
wir haben einen rückgang wenn wir die
wachsende wohnbevölkerung dazu zählen
könnte ich sagen es ist ein leichter
rückgang
andererseits 10.000 sind immer noch viel
aber das ist ja ein symptom davon dass
die meisten auch jungen menschen die
eben sexuell aktiv werden eine
einigermaßen gute aufklärung
sexualaufklärung haben und zweitens
einen zugang zu verhütungsmitteln
man sieht ja genau in jenen ländern in
denen das restriktiv gehandhabt wird in
den abtreibungen verboten sind teilweise
sogar ein verhütungsmittel verfemt sind
oder eben die religion speziell die
katholische kirche noch den finger drauf
halten kann sagen kondome sind des
teufels da hat man dann einfach viele
ungewollte schwangerschaften also das
mittel gegen zu viele abtreibungen ist
meiner meinung nach eben kein zurück
kommen auf diese fristenlösung sondern
eine gute ausbildung auch eben in der
staatsschule über einen
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit
sexualität also es ist nicht euer re
kontraproduktiv
ich muss es annehmen ja irland jede land
das gerade gerade gelockert also früher
mussten ja irische mädchen und frauen
junge frauen die mussten nach london
fliegen um um eine abtreibung machen zu
können und irland hat jetzt das
blasphemie verbot gekippt es das war vor
20 jahren war das noch das war schlimmer
als das oberwallis teilweise also dieses
er lang und das hat jetzt eine riesen
entwicklung gemacht also blasphemie
verbot weg und abtreibung liberalisiert
chapeau wir wissen doch unsachgemäße
abtreibung ist eine der häufigsten
todesursachen weltweit für frauen also
das würde ich schon auch das fieber
sowie hintergrund haben sie das vorher
gemerkt genau das ist das geht gar nicht
also das abdrängen dann die die
illegalität durch verbot
es ist das gebot angeklungen du sollst
nicht töten bei dem einen ethiker und
theologen
was sagen sie dazu steht ja in der
hebräischen bibel ohne zu übersetzungen
die nicht allgemein da steht da steht ja
nicht
lothar ob du sollst nicht töten sondern
da steht alle tiere zach du sollst nicht
morden töten darf man um zum beispiel
ein beispiel zu nehmen hier aus unserem
thema wenn jetzt da hinten jemand kommt
mit einem gewehr und ich sehe dass und
ich hätte hier zufällig auch eins drauf
ich töten um unschuldiges blutvergießen
zu verhindern
also man es gibt situationen wo ich
töten muss so die ganze aber eben in den
zehn geboten da stehst du sollst nicht
morden also das was der da hinten tun
würde wenn er das stünde das war mord
und das soll man nicht
sie haben sie angedeutet es gibt eine
stelle im in der hebräischen bibel im
alten testament oder im ersten testament
sagen wir da geht es um diese frage sie
haben es gesagt auge um auge ich habe
aus gehört da geht es eigentlich um eine
limitierung der gewalt und nicht wie wir
erwarten würden wenn mir jemand einen
zaun raus schlägt würde ich ihm
wahrscheinlich mehrere zähne ausschlagen
oder als eine limitierung der gewalt
aber was gewinnen wir nochmal für das
thema ab 3
als vielleicht auch zu dem was wir
gerade in dem film gesehen haben
das erschien mir sehr passiv also gott
schafft leben und dass ich bin das opfer
von dieser schöpfung das ist ja
eigentlich nicht so sondern zum beispiel
gott schafft sechs werktage und das den
schabbat wird muss ich machen oder gott
schafft den menschen und die
beschneidung machen wir also die welt
ist geschaffen aber sie muss
weiterentwickelt werden da ist wir sind
als menschen mitarbeiter in gottes
schöpfung und durch die heutigen fragen
sind entscheidungen halt anders also
früher konnte man nicht wissen ob ein
kind behindert geboren wird oder nicht
heute habe ich diese entscheidung und
ich treffe diese entscheidung einerseits
mit dem was ich am anfang gesagt hab
hohe heiligkeit des lebens aber
gleichzeitig bin ich mit beteiligt an
der schöpfung und kann entscheiden
das macht uns als menschen ja aus und ja
und diese entscheidung die sie begleiten
wir dann im gespräch und oder wie immer
sie dann fällt bleiben ist eine frage
die eine geschichte hat oder die
debatten sind alt über diese frage der
abtreibung die frage hält aber ein neues
gewicht oder neue dringlichkeit durch
neue genetische untersuchungen durch
bluttests ein paar milliliter blut der
werdenden mutter genügen
daraus lässt sich das erbgut des embryos
analysieren
neben möglichen behinderungen und
erbkrankheiten auch das geschlecht schon
ab der siebten schwangerschaftswoche
wenn der embryo nicht das gewünschte
geschlecht hat bleiben so mehrere wochen
für eine abtreibung gentests sind bei
schwangeren frauen groß in mode
bestätigt gynäkologe daniel surbeck vom
berner inselspital und er weiß dass es
zu abtreibungen kommt weil das kind das
falsche geschlecht habe als dass sich
das linie minderheit wird das volk und
abriss rundfunk und das schauen wir hin
und wieder habe dass er die
schweizerinnen wie migrantinnen und
andere ethnische hintergründe
was schätzen sie wie viel fell während
das opfer pro jahr schweizweit ich
schätze dass es sich unter pfalz in
orbit office in der geschlechter
selektion hat der gesetzgeber nun einen
riegel vor
oben das geschlecht des embryos dach den
eltern künftig bis zur zwölften
schwangerschaftswoche nicht mitgeteilt
werden
sp politikerin pascale bruderer hat
diese verschärfung angeregt mit diesen
tests lässt sich das geschlecht
bestimmen bevor die zwölf wochen frist
für abtreibungen abgelaufen ist
mit der herkömmlichen ultraschall
methode war dies nicht möglich
da bin ich klar denn einig dass es nicht
toleriert werden kann
der gesellschaft und auf unserer
rechtsordnung das wacken richtigen oder
falschen geschlecht sbb oft gebraucht
wird oder nicht das geschlecht des
kindes den eltern bewusst zu
verheimlichen verstoße gegen ihr recht
auf wissen kritisieren ethiker und es
beschränke auch das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der eltern ja
diese neuen bluttests geben aufschluss
über mögliche genetische krankheiten
aber auch über das geschlecht
sie gehen wir nicht automatisch
aufschluss und der arzt die ärztin kann
dann entscheiden was wirklich den eltern
kommunizieren ich hab das geschlecht
unseres kindes auch gewusst bevor ist da
war weil es beim ultraschall
offensichtlich war aber es sei denn
jemand würde im ausland einen solchen
test machen genau man kann ja immer noch
hinterfragt ist es ist viel früher
möglich oder ausschalten sie sehe die
frage was sind relevante eigenschaften
die es den eltern ermöglichen zu
entscheiden ob dieses kind leben soll
oder nicht und das ist keine relevanten
schafft und wer entscheidet das
eigentlich gut aber jetzt haben wir das
gesetz vor uns in der schweiz dass es
verboten ist in den ersten treffer im
ersten zwölf wochen der schwangerschaft
das geschlecht zu sagen wie reagieren
sie darauf
also das wäre ein beispiel für eine
schwierige frage weil man muss einen
guten grund haben um abzutreiben also
eben auf der basis einerseits es ist
möglich aber oder es ist verboten aber
es gibt immer ein grund warum ich es
mache und diese jüdischen response die
sagen da im moment zu der frage
geschlechter auswahl das ist kein grund
aber zum beispiel genetische behinderung
das ist ein grund und bei uns begann
eine ganz neue debatte in den 70er
jahren
es gibt eine genetische krankheit tay
sachs die in der jüdischen gemeinschaft
sehr häufig ist häufiger als in der
anders sonst das ist eine krankheit wo
eigentlich ab dem sechsten monat oder so
eigentlich das kind nur noch schwächer
wird also körperlich geistig und dann
nach drei jahren stirbt und da gab es
fing die debatte an und da war in
amerika die position dass man gesagt hat
nein man darf deswegen nicht
dieses kind diesen fotos mit 3 6 ab
treiben und in israel hat man gesagt ja
vielleicht ist das auch eine spiegelt
die gesellschaft wider dass amerika eine
freiere einstellung hat und man da als
jüdische gemeinschaft gesagt hat wir
müssen grenzen setzen und ein israel der
andere ausgangs bundes aber noch mal
zurück zu der frage mit dem das war
jetzt zu einer möglichen behinderung zur
frage des geschlechts die mehrheit der
nationalen ethischen kommission in der
schweiz hat gesagt das ist eine
schlechte idee dieses verbot weil es
wird dann eine gewichtung eingeführt wie
sehen sie das
es ist ein rückschritt hinter die den
grundsatz der fristenlösung also bis
zwölf fragen wird nicht noch einen grund
aber ich habe jetzt eine realpolitische
antwort gegeben wenn man wenn ich wie
realpolitisch weitergehe dann sehe ich
auch die probleme wenn es eben aus einer
religiös patriarchalen gemeinschaft
diese idee gibt knaben sind mehr wert
als mädchen also ich polemisieren macht
jetzt ein bisschen schwarz weiß aber
grundsätzlich ist es dann dass es gibt
auch in europa es gibt eine gute
dokumentation über ich glaube albanien
wo dann dieses geschlechterverhältnis so
kross asymmetrisch wird dass man sich
über die zukunft der gesellschaft gruppe
also gedanken machen muss und da habe
ich in meinem kopf zwei verschiedene
widerstrebende prinzipien
also es ist ein dummer grund wirklich
eben nach dem geschlecht zu gehen aber
es könnte sein dass man gewisse also
wenn die prädisposition für gewisse
genetische krankheiten wenn ich mit
dieser partnerin ein kind habe ist es
teilweise gibt es genetische krankheiten
die dann nur der glaube bekommt oder nur
das mädchen und da fängt es dann auch
wieder an schlauer zu werden wenn man
jetzt weiß das ist ein knabe der kann
gar nicht von uns
zwei dieser krankheit erben also es ist
auch da wieder nicht schwarz und weiß
doch sie sagen eben auch es ist eine
leichte relativierung sag ich jetzt oder
der fristenlösung ich frage mal weil sie
jetzt dass eine beispiel angesprochen
haben albanien sadiku mal damaliger noch
mal zu ihnen in indien ist das ja ein
großes thema was geschieht dort in bezug
auf eben abtreibung von weiblichen föten
ein kind ist ein kind in religiösen sich
aber indien ist ein riese gebiet es gibt
da unterschiedliche kulturen
es gibt auch ein kultur wo ein mädchen
groß wenn sie heiraten möchte dann die
eltern gibt so viel geld und ein
kletterhaus sie muss alles mitbringen
wenn eine familie sehr armut ist viele
machen diese abtreibung wenn sie
verkenne dass auch einfache mit dem
kultur zu tun
in indien ist es ja wenn ich es richtig
gelesen haben verboten dass das
geschlecht mitgeteilt wird streng
verboten gleichwohl gibt es offenbar
sehr häufig abtreibungen aufgrund des
geschlechts eben bei weiblichen föten
genauso elend illegal machen sie auch
die kontrolle und das passiert da habe
ich auch viel im medien gehört aber wir
kommen alle aus also meistens aus sri
lanka
damit ist von meiner urgroßmutter so
habe ich nicht so viel erlebt also ich
glaube dass es etwas mit den knien oder
bodenkultur ganz anders also in indien
gibt es auch einige regionen männer muss
geld bringen nicht nur frauen also das
ist ganz anders also wieder so eine
frage wo eben ein verbot offenbar nicht
die gewünschte wirkung dann erzielt wir
haben gehört in der schweiz geschätzte
100 fälle pro jahr
vielleicht da bedeutender die frage eben
wenn es um behinderungen geht die
absehbar sind sie haben das aus
jüdischer sicht geschildert
wie ist das in der christlichen sicht da
ist das christentum hat sehr klar
bezieht position für die schwachen und
von daher ist es ein jahr gerade zum
schwachen und behinderten leben und auf
der anderen seite
ich habe sehr oft zwei seelen in meiner
brust hier bin ich mit einem gesunden
kind einer frau einer familie zu sagen
tja das ist jetzt gerade eure aufgabe
und ihr müsst ja ihr müsst ja sagen zum
schwachen das würde ich gerne auf die
gesellschaft zurück beziehen und stellt
noch einmal zurück auf die geschlechter
war das ist ja dann auch noch brisante
man sieht dass die rate der abtreibungen
unter migrantinnen sehr viel höher ist
in der schweiz als unter schweizerinnen
dass bei 1 anderen migrantinnen aus
afrika zum beispiel ist es fast neunmal
höher als bei schweizerinnen und da die
ganze kultur ist es eine zu schnelle
problemlösung wenn man sagt die sollen
einfach die dürfen einfach nicht wissen
ob es ein mädchen oder ein junge ist
oder ob es behindert ist das ist
wirklich und da wieder zurück zu den
behinderungen glaube ich eine große
aufgabe für die ganze gesellschaft nur
sagen was er machen wir wie wollen wir
gesellschaft sein wollen wir das nur die
gesunden schönen starken ein recht auf
leben haben und eben diejenigen die
ausgewählt sind oder wollen wir daran
arbeiten dass wir eine gesellschaft sind
die gerade zusammen mit menschen die
schwach behindert nicht dem ideal
entsprechen die un wollen wir
akzeptieren und spüren lernen dass die
uns etwas lehren können ich habe meine
schwester hat das jüngste von ihren vier
kindern ist behindert und sie hat wäre
erlaubnis gegeben sie zu zitieren weil
ich gesagt habe eben wer bin ich mit
gesundem kinder sie sagt ja und ich
spüre wirklich das gibt uns auch etwas
und ich wollte es nicht
ich wollte nicht ich hätte abgedrängt
das ist richtig und wichtig sind
wohin gehen wir wenn wir das sukzessive
aus merzen das finde ich ganz schwierig
soziale verantwortung also ich wollte
einfach betonen dass
dann wenig mit dem christentum zu tun es
kann ein christlicher impetus sein dass
man eine solidarische gesellschaft in
dem bereich haben will
aber ich bin da auch für die
solidarische gemeinschaft denn man muss
auch wissen auch das sind zahlen es
nicht einfach nur geburts oder gen
defekte die zu behinderungen oder eben
schädigungen führen denn ganz viele
dinge passieren einem genetisch gesunden
menschen während seines arbeitslebens
sport leben einer geburt ja oder bei der
geburt und deswegen ist es nötig dass
wir diese solidarität haben das muss
aber eben nicht religiös begründet oder
behinderter gründet sein das denke ich
ist ganz wichtig denn unsere
gesellschaft wird je längere gottlose
also die menschen nehmen das nicht mehr
so als ein gutes argument war dass steht
halt in diesem heiligen buch da gibt es
einschlägige argumente teilweise aber es
gibt eben auch das gegenteil
und für mich ist auch ganz interessant
und wichtig was macht denn die natur
also 15 bis 20 prozent der befruchteten
eizellen gehen einfach natürlich also
auch als spontan an bord ab bis sechste
bis zwölfte woche und da weiß man nicht
so genau also wenn man religiös wäre
müsste man sagen gott hat das
abgetrieben und noch krasser mehr als
die hälfte der befruchteten eizellen
gehen vor der sechsten woche ab die
meisten frauen merken gar nicht dass sie
dort eine befruchtete eizelle hatten
sondern denken dass jetzt eine stärkere
blutung und deswegen ist es für mich ein
nicht argument wenn man sagt schwupps da
kommt die seele reihen und jetzt ist das
ein dermaßen starkes schützenswertes gut
denn dieses gedankenexperiment wenn ich
rein laufe in eine brennende fertilität
klinik also da wo man
dass das hat und da schreit ein
einjähriges baby und da ist diese kanne
mit ungefähr 100 tiefgekühlte millionen
ich möchte diesen evangelikalen sehen
der diese kanne nimmt und sagt nein das
sind 100 seelen drin und hier dieses
kind da bin ich für diesen reality check
und da bin ich dafür einfach mal karten
auf den tisch und und genauer werden uns
voraus gespurt dazu seele wir waren ja
noch einmal zurück zur gesellschaft das
nochmals stark machen weil ich denke
unser thema ist ja auch ein thema wie
ist unsere gesellschaft und ich würde
sagen wir sind leben um wieder
zurückzukommen ist verschiedenheit ich
würde da nicht mit schwachheit
argumentieren weil ich glaub menschen
mit handicap sind enorm stark nicht jede
frau ist so stark wie das kind was ihr
dann vielleicht haben würde
deshalb würde ich da eben auch lassen
dass immer die entscheidung der frau
aber ich würde plädieren dass wir eine
gesellschaft sind wo jeder anders sein
darf und anderssein ist andere
sexualität anderes geschlecht andere
andere fähigkeiten die einen sind
vielleicht geistig etwas anders als
andere
er ist ein andersartigkeit und das macht
ja das leben überhaupt das so spannend
und wir können voneinander lernen nur
weil wir verschieden sind aber deswegen
darf es doch nicht nur die situation die
entscheiden der einzelnen frauen seien
deswegen werde ich mich so gegen dieses
isoliert sein und sich sagen dass ein
reality check das ist gerade nicht die
realität wie viel gelegenheit gibt es in
einem brennenden in einer brennenden
fertilität klinik sich diese
entscheidung zu stellen das problem ist
tatsächlich dass die entscheidungen sind
immer nur für oder gegen ein ungeborenes
kind
das ist unser problem aber das darf
nicht einfach nur man darf nicht aber
nur sagen tja liebe frau deine
entscheidung dein bauch dein recht das
ist eine extreme überform würde ich
einmal behaupten als einzelne frauen die
männer und die familien rundherum die
werden da niemand souverän vergessen
aber diese quest gibt es ja und was ist
wenn du das kannst also ich mache man
kann ja wer kann ich das traue ich mir
das zu und dann braucht man eben schon
gespräch mit freunden oder eben zum
beispiel in ein
religiösen gemeinschaft und dann am ende
wie immer waren die entscheidung trifft
die ist so oder so dann stehe aber ich
brauchte der gesellschaft auf der ich
vertrauen kann
wenn ich mich dafür entscheiden daran
hat es auch mit unterstützung
genau niemand eben jemand das gerne
allein und ganz bestimmt ist niemand
gerne allein gelassen bei so einer
entscheidung deswegen soll so etwas mit
bedacht geschehen aber man muss auch
verstehen wenn jemand vergewaltigt
worden ist und dann ist sie schwanger
geworden dann ist es für mich auch
wieder eine ohrfeige wenn diese leute
möchten also wenn die er und noch einmal
wenn die könnten dann würden die ins
gesetz steigen das wird ausgetragen und
dann von mir aus noch dann sind sie gut
ich ja dann darf sie das zur adoption
freigeben
also da sind dann teilweise totalitäre
ideen mit religions- hintergrund man
kann aber auch eine frage haben sie
gehören meistens religionsgemeinschaften
doch eben eine ausnahme gemacht aber
wirklich gerne alle fragen uns viel
liberales und deswegen ist es auch schön
dass das im moment oder mittlerweile
eine raum strömung ist das ist das
schöne daran
auch in der evangelischen sicht ist es
bei behinderung ein klarer fall für das
leben oder gibt es da spieler wie es im
judentum offenbar der fall ist
in gewissen strömungen naja ich bin ja
nun reformiert und wir haben niemanden
der für uns entscheidet nicht wir haben
in der schweiz wieder einen bischof noch
eine wifi noch ein lehramt noch jetzt in
meiner meyer und tradition eine
biblische aussagen würde sagen können da
steht ist insofern gibt's immer
spielraum
aber ich glaube es gibt spielraum zu
diskutieren und gerade mit diesem nicht
invasiven vorgeburtlichen test wo er
auch trisomie 21
getestet wird der und wo frauen familien
zu 90 prozent wenn sie dieses
testergebnis haben sich für eine
abtreibung entscheiden und s21 ist halt
nun immer ein geburtsgebrechen ich finde
das was sind wir für eine
gesellschaftlich wird nie da bin ich
sehr einverstanden einer frau ins gesäß
ins gesetz festschreiben dass sie auf
jeden fall immer austragen muss aber
lasst uns darüber nachdenken wie
behindertenfreundlich sind wir uns
viel stärke völlig einer stadt kommt uns
da entgegen mitmenschen mit gerade mit
sony 21 und insofern ja es gibt viel
spielraum aber lasst uns lasst uns mit
dem bewusstsein und ich zitiere nochmals
den papst
was wie lösen welche probleme lösen wir
eigentlich so und welche seiten jahren
das lesen den ball gespielt wann beginnt
eigentlich menschliches leben
menschliches leben beginnt wenn die
schwiegermutter tot ist und die kinder
also es war jetzt die bärchen war das
ist ein jüdischen witz wenn ich das
richtig
also ich gehe jetzt wieder schläge von
meiner frau zu hause ich kann aber
ähnlich erfreulich dass beginnt wenn das
kind das vestibül verlassen hat und
jetzt überall muss da überlegen was ist
jetzt das vestibül die gebärmutter oder
die vagina also allgemein kann man sagen
wenn das kind geboren ist dann beginnt
das leben
okay das ist schon mal eine these geburt
nein ich würde da auch wir können also
rechtlich mich in der schwangerschaft
war dass sobald ich wusste ich bin
schwanger war das werden des
menschliches leben das war ein jemand da
drin
und die haben sie nach namen gegeben
insofern war die geburt nur noch ein
sichtbar werden dessen was vorher
definitiv schon da war also da ist im
judentum bis 40 tage ist das wasser dann
ist es ein teil der motor also ist ein
rechtsdenken ja und dann eben bei der
geburt ist es eine rechtsperson deshalb
ist eben vor der geburt da kann eben die
mutter entscheiden was sie mit ihren
teilen macht nach der geburt ist es ein
eigenständiges schützenswerte
rechtsperson na ja und das ist eher
intuitiv in das teil kickt und mich dazu
bringt dass wir trotz übel ist morgens
aber was heißt das schon wasser dass da
auch gar nicht ein grund sein braucht
also dass man in den ersten 40 tagen das
kommt so ein bisschen von aristoteles
und so wann ist eigentlich da die seele
da das judentum dann übernommen
rechtlich gar nichts eigentlich dann
übrigens alles totales hatte die lustige
idee dann glaube ich von thomas von
aquin übernommen und die katholische
lehre dann geplant von thomas von aquin
von aristoteles übernommen dass die
seele beim männlichen vögel bis 14 tage
reinkommt bei der frau braucht das also
80 dass ein boxer langsam auch wieder
sexismus in eben alles totaler gehöre
eher auf meiner seite also das ist ein
problem aber ernsthaft man müsse sich
eben schon antworten menschliches
schützenswert das leben eben nicht nur
potenziell also ich meine bei einer
spätabtreibung da das ist für mich total
eine andere frage also da wo die die die
schwangerschaftswochen sind wo das kind
außerhalb der gebärmutter wenn es jetzt
einen unfall gibt eine eine sectio eine
note von sektion und dann ist es
außerhalb des dessen das gebären unter
lebensfähig das für mich ein total
anderer fall
deswegen ich finde man ist mit diesen
zwölf wochen bei der fristenlösung ist
man absichtlich an eine sehr frühe
grenze gegangen
die frau hat zeit das zu überlegen sie
hat eine periode ausgelassen sie habe
hoffentlich zeit und unterstützung sei
dass in der familie oder bei einem arzt
oder psychologen oder einfach freunde
und chrysler stützen kann hoffentlich
aber etwas so etwas das außerhalb schon
lebensfähig ist einfach so weg zu tun
da habe ich also größte mühe das ist das
argument mit dem verfolger also dass man
sagen kann wenn da jemand kommt und
bedroht leben dass ein fötus eben wenn
das leben der mutter bedroht
in jeder phase also mein mann ist recht
des landes ist das recht also wurde
jetzt in der schweiz nicht irgendwelche
religions- gesetzlichen dinge und da
gilt schweizer recht ja aber dann ist da
wo das hört sich ja auch ein leben aber
wenn die mutter in gefahr ist dass ich
und wie gesagt es gibt eine diskussion
was ist gefahr
und da denke ich du musst sehr gut
geführt werden um der gesellschaft will
um unserer werte hinter gesetzt aber ich
hänge doch bei der frage des anfangs des
lebens ist mir leid sie haben wir jetzt
wirklich überrascht weil ich die
katholische position liegen wo kommt ja
das christentum judentum dass es jetzt
so offen ist im judentum und dann
wirklich eine punktlandung also wie es
der paragraph gesagt hat in dieser ein
spiel sequenz das einfach von anfang an
also eher verspielt weil von einer sagen
also 18 18 9 ja wir haben diese sätze
gesehen also dass die seele mit der zeit
eben das wort nehmen es katholik die
serien sexismus bei thomas von hören war
ja das in ihren augen fortschrittlich
der neuen entwicklung ist die seele dazu
kommt das hat sich tatsächlich geändert
jedenfalls in der römisch-katholischen
position mit der bestellung von anfang
an aber ich finde wir erklären sie diese
unterschiede
die haben gab es auch eine ganz andere
auffassung von seele und weil die serie
spielt für uns rechtlich gar keine rolle
von recom irgendwann vierzigsten tag
oder bei der befruchtung oder waren weiß
ich so genau wann die eigentlich kommt
ist eigentlich auch egal weil die seele
ist rein
die kommt von gott und wenn der fötus zb
dann sterben würde würde sie zu gott
zurückgehen
also da gibt's nicht bei uns ein problem
mit ungetauften seelen oder es gibt
alles geht sondern auch nicht wir haben
es noch schöner will wir brauchen garten
gar keine seele also das ist
sie brauchen medizin dass ich auch mal
interessante position von dem vom
medizinischen fortschritt abhängig zu
machen wenn menschliches leben entsteht
also wenn es außerhalb das ist ja
mittlerweile schon fast 23 woche oder so
und der medizinische fortschritt sich
noch weiter entwickelt geht es noch
weiter zurück also eigentlich würde ich
eigentlich nie eigentlich würde ich
sagen menschliches leben ist also ist
bei der verschmelzung von spermium und
eizelle da aber das ist noch nicht oder
seele gesamte und ich hab nix gesorgt
von es ist absolut schützenswert
da wissen wir jetzt dass ich ein es kann
sein dass daraus ein mensch wird oder
aber es kann noch kein schmerzempfinden
und in abwägung mit der entscheidung der
frau geht die entscheidung der stau bis
zur zwölften woche vor
und bei all diesen dingen ist eben mir
ist auch die leidensfähigkeit ein punkt
und eben auch das mögliche leiden der
frau und mutter die vielleicht eine
risikoschwangerschaft hätten schon
einmal erwähnt noch das kann auch bei
einer jungen frau zb die die lehre noch
nicht fertig hat entschuldigung auch das
leben der also das ist auch eine chance
sie sagen es gibt einen punkt oder eine
entwicklung ich muss hier anfang machen
bei werte doch am ende unserer sendung
sind ja ein bettler ich haben wir zum
schluss noch die frage in die runde
geben möchte einfach eine kurze antwort
die religionsgemeinschaften können wir
darauf zurück ihre aufgabe wie sehen sie
als gebot als verbot gebe oder als
hoffnung und unterstützung also wie ich
ja vorher schon gesagt aber als
unterstützung der frauen in der
entscheidungsfindung
also ich würde jetzt nicht mal meine
position ist die gesellschaft soll
verschieden sein also das würde ja aber
das kann ich nicht ja so wenn ich ein
seelsorgerisches gespräch führt dann
geht es ums zuhören und gucken wo sind
eigentlich bedürfnis zu viel fragen viel
hören und dann begleiten wo hindern die
entscheidung ausgeht dass ich die mit
unterstütze ich finde es gut dass
religion ihr längere weniger rolle
spielt bei solchen entscheidungen
ich bin aber dafür dass wir mit
liberalen offenen progressiven
religiösen strömungen die gutes wollen
auch die helfen uns um anniston uns
steigern können auch helfen mit sie
müssen sich bewusst sein welche leute
bei ihnen im boot mit paddeln und das
schlimme ist häufig sind diejenigen die
fordern diesen lautsprecher haben und
dann zu rufen abtreibung ist ist
auftragsmord die oben also wunder ist
noch nicht aus der kirche ausgetreten
deswegen wenn man sich von so was
distanzieren will geht das am besten mit
einem kirchenaustritt und das war mein
wort zum sonntag war dort meine predigt
halt jetzt leider kann ich nicht aus der
katholischen kirche austreten weil ich
da gar nicht drin war und ich will dich
dass der protestantischen aus der
reformierten austreten weil ich auch gar
keinen sinn weil religion schon jetzt
christliche religion ich weiß die
anderen nicht dürfen sondern weil das
knie ist von der ich am meisten verstehe
den ich spielen schon eine rolle in
einem land was noch sehr stark von
dieser tradition geprägt ist ich sehe
uns als unterstützer als ermöglicher
aber auch als erinnerer und
herausforderer eben zu sagen leute was
steht hier auf den spielen einfach noch
mal lasst uns darüber regen lass uns
noch nicht zu schnell oder fahne steht
ein gedicht und ein eine zeile ist mir
geblieben
schnelle dinge sind verrat lasst uns
nicht das ungeborene leben verraten das
ist kein gebot und kein shampoo zu einer
einladung zum gespräch
ich habe bei ihnen frau birthler noch
heraus gehört es gibt in dieser position
auch eine begleitung von menschen von
frauen die abgetrieben haben ja also es
gibt so gerade jetzt so im 20ten 21
jahrhundert viele neue rituale besonders
für frauen und lebenssituation von
frauen und abtreibung ist eins dieser
rituale da ist eine vielfalt also ich
hab ja erwähnt es gibt ein gebet nach
schwangerschaftsabbruch es gibt es
rituale wo man dann in die miet vergeht
als reinigung und verschiedene sehr
kreativ das macht man in der gemeinde
mit der vision ist nicht festgelegt ist
aber so das gibt es aber auch von
christlichen anbietern und von uns
humanistischen ritual begleiter wird das
auch gemacht also dass die pforte zum
beispiel einen abschluss haben können
dass sie das würde wohl überdenken
können das gibt es also in
nicht nur in den religionen sondern auch
bei weltanschauungsgemeinschaften wie
bei uns das sind also können und es gibt
ja immer wieder auch schwierige momente
ja also die wende geburt gewesen wäre
oder der erste geburtstag oder so dass
man da im grunde sensibel begleitet ich
habe viel gelernt das war für mich ein
sehr interessanter punkt ganz herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
annette büchler war dem coach von
christina ausdauer und saß iq berlin kam
[Musik]
ja
nächste woche nächste woche geht es in
der sternstunde religion um den neuen
kinofilm female pressure um die
sexualität von frauen
genauer um den kampf für eine
selbstbestimmte weibliche sexualität und
jetzt geht es hier gleich weiter mit der
sternstunde philosophie
mein kollege yves bost diskutiert mit
dem basler stararchitekten herzog über
die macht der architektur
[Applaus]
[Musik]